let's get into that first story my
friends i hope you are prepared from the
daily mail
we could have some trouble brewing how
understaffed police forces across
america are bracing for written house
acquittal chicago cancels weekend days
off as portland lapd and washington dc
all monitor trial across the country
police departments who have been under
siege politically who have lost funding
who have seen resignations and
retirements
and police quitting i believe baltimore
is understaffed by hundreds of officers
now are bracing for the next wave of blm
antifa riots why
well they've been set up over the past
year the media has lied about kyle
rittenhouse and the crazy thing is
if this prosecutor in the cal written
house case is an ideologue
i think he wants there to be a mistrial
because he knows kyle rittenhouse was
acting in self-defense he knows this
trial should have never happened he
knows kyle redenhaus is facing an
innocence verdict so you don't get ruled
innocent but what i mean is that the
jury is going to say across the board
outright not guilty on all counts
because they believe he's innocent not
just not guilty so what's the best thing
an ideologue who wants riding can do
sabotage the trial to such a degree that
forces the judge to issue a mistrial so
the mainstream media and establishment
narrative becomes there was no justice
kyle rittenhouse got away with it and
that's what's happening slate.com wrote
an article saying don't blame here's
what they put don't blame judge
schroeder if kyle writtenhouse goes free
and they show even aaron rupar saying
it's not going well for the prosecutor
what's gonna happen is in my opinion
they'll come out and they'll say
the trial was bad
the prosecutor was bad and because of
that justice didn't occur the system is
broken and then they will riot
i hope you guys are ready well you said
if uh there's no justice and what's the
motto of of a lot of the blm activists
if there's no justice
right no peace absolutely and so it's
almost like a mathematical certainty how
could you not expect rioting in downtown
dc because we didn't get justice or
kenosha or
think about it this way if the jury
comes back and says not guilty on all
counts it's really hard to maintain a no
justice you know no peace narrative but
they will they'll still say oh the the
jurors were corrupt and the judge was
biased
however rodney king still if the jury
comes back a lot of people are going to
be like you know a jury ruled on this
one it may be the wrong verdict but it
will defuse a lot of it if there's a
mistrial with prejudice and cal can't be
retried then they're going to say
the case is corrupt the system is broken
and a white supremacist goes for you
i mean if you live in a major city
you're already kind of dealing with an
onslaught of a lot of violence i mean
there's incredibly horribly horrible
stories i just tweeted about the two
women who were attacked in central park
there was a 13 year old girl that was
also attacked in unspeakable ways in the
bronx uh so if you're if you're living
in like new york city you are already
dealing with an onslaught of a huge
major crime wave in seattle government
officials just had to hire security
guards so they could be walked to the
ferry um mayor de blasio is ducking
questions about black lives matter
talking about how they're going to riot
uh and there's going to be fire and
bloodshed if they don't get their way
with the policy that the next mayor
wants to implement and more police
officers and this was because defund the
police got the anti-crime unit removed
the anti-crime unit are plain clothes
officers that literally stop crime in
progress the activists came out
said we don't want police well crime
crime hasn't gone up in new york in the
last year and a half so it really the
crime unit i'm being facetious
like wait a minute murder is up 47
yeah in new york city so larceny is up
like 15 20
i was saying this earlier like if if the
fact that they're saying if you put in
this anti-crime unit back
we're going to kill people it's like
evidence as to why we need the
anti-crime unit right
that's insane
let's let's let's rope it back to to the
written house trial specifically
chris hayes comes out and he says on his
show he's changing his narrative this is
amazing there was a super cut tucker
carlson played it where all of these
mainstream outlets were like this kid's
a white supremacist who crossed state
lines with an illegal weapon to hunt
down black you know uh black lives
matter civil rights activists all fake
narrative
now that people are waking up and
they're forced to reconcile this there's
a viral tweet
where a woman says
i'm very perceptive and i only just
found out kyle redenhaus's victims were
white yeah and all the responses are
like wait what really really i didn't
know that and they're all saying the
same thing embarrassing well because the
and this woman was like my progressive
bubble told me a fake like the wrong
story
so now chris hayes narrative is do we
really want to live in a society where
political problems are solved with guns
you see where he's pivoting now to
kyle rittenhouse will be acquitted
because he has a real claim of
self-defense but this goes to show why
guns are bad
that's what they're going for already
when leftists on twitter when anna
kasparian when chris hayes are now
admitting cal written out was acting in
self-defense or at least saying that to
a great degree
an acquittal is going to happen yeah it
is it is so obvious that they can't even
deny it anymore but you know that means
riots will happen well there's other
people doubling down on the insanity and
the divide and conquer agenda like
msnbc's joy reid who said that the court
proceedings are quote white privilege on
steroids again what does this have to do
with anything about race i was going to
say all the people are white in this
particular case but there's a lot of
people that are verified spreading a lot
of fake news about this there's a
verified twitter account that literally
is telling people that kyle was chasing
people down and shooting them and the
tweet has gone viral tens of thousands
of likes not factual not correct jenna
yeah west virginia democrat former
former democrat state democrat former
yeah former but he's still a very
prominent figure and has uh when he
government organization when he first
came out publicly and said he wanted to
run a lot of people including myself
were like this is a moderate democrat
this is good the dude has gone insane he
posted a tweet where he said
new video bombshell video shows kyle
renaus was chasing the uh rosen bomb
literally never happened this democrat
dude in west virginia of all places
posted overt lies why
look i think too often we give the
benefit of the doubt to these people too
often we're like he must just be
ignorant at this point i'm like no he
wants murder and death this guy wants
people to die he is an evil mother these
people all do this because i will tell
you this at a certain point
at a certain point i will stop giving
you the benefit of the doubt if if you
have a year plus and an active trial
where a major component in the case is
the prosecution is criminally charging
dominic black for supplying a a firearm
illegally to cal rittenhouse that is
part of the proceedings and you don't
bother to even look at it and then you
make a meme
where you make up fake evidence which
results in people saying this proves
kyle rittenhouse is a murderer you want
the destruction you want the death and
you want people killed evil people it is
it is incredibly ironic that they are
still doubling down on this one what
happened in kenosha happened because of
media lies about jacob blake being a
poor innocent victim and being shot an
unarmed black man being shot by police
he had a knife yes he literally had a
knife
he just assaulted a woman yes yes but
the media is doubling down on this it's
gonna happen again and i'm starting to
think that this is exactly what they
want it's very hard to argue anything
else at this point well tim some would
say your comments are a little bit
hyperbolic about them being evil but
there is a lot of lack of empathy here
whether it's lebron james that just
tweeted to fifty point three million of
his followers look look look no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no i i'm
gonna stop you right there
hyperbolic
some would say it's hyperbolic but i'm
saying they don't have any empathy and
that's your largest target though
with 5 000 plus retweets yeah is sitting
in his room and he goes i'm going to
make up something
hold on there a minute he's like i'm
going to make something up
i am going to fabricate information
yo
tell me i'm being hyperbolic when i say
it is evil to sit there and say i'm
going to lie about a kid who was
attacked and nearly killed
you said that he's calling for death and
then you're saying he's just lacking
empathy we watched no no no no no no i'm
saying a lot of other people are lacking
empathy towards this entire situation
especially during a very key emotional
aspect of this which adds to your claim
uh because someone you know someone just
randomly hearing what you just said
right now would say oh that's hyperbolic
but to add to your claim there is an
extensive amount of lack of empathy from
a lot of higher institutions like usa
today they wrote an opinion piece that's
mind-boggling to see in an amer in one
of america's biggest newspaper they
wrote a headline that said kyle renton
house deserves an award for his
melodramatic performance on the witness
listen listen
i think at a certain point the problem
we face is that
we
conservatives libertarians
keep giving these people the benefit of
the doubt every step of the way
jacob blake that does his name right
jacob blake is the guy he assaults a
woman yes
in her bed
with her and
and and her kit and and this guy
tries ste taking a vehicle i don't i
think he was stealing i'm not sure
with
this woman's children in it after
assaulting her the police show up he
fights them
they tell him to stop he grabs a knife
the cops shoot him in defense
nfl players wear his name they put his
name on their helmets this guy assaulted
a woman in her bed if you get the drift
family-friendly show
he then drew a knife on the police i'm
not a big fan of the cops particularly
kenosha cops or chicago pd but these are
the facts
when you have people like ojeda
sitting in your in the room or office
looking at everything going on and he
says
after all of the destruction the 30 plus
dead in the george floyd riots
i would like to add to that fire i would
like to lie a a a young man's life hangs
in the balance
he went there to render aid as did gage
gross kreutz and i will say to both of
them they both went down there in
similar circumstances they both went
down there with guns arguably well his
was literally illegal arguably cal right
now has an exemption but that's a matter
of law they both said they wanted to
render aid now one gross kreutz is a bit
older and he is an ideologue kyle
rittenhouse wanted to be a cop he's
certainly on the other end of the
ideological spectrum
chaos ensues a man who just got out of
jail in a mental hospital who has for a
lack of a better term committed grievous
crimes against children which again
family-friendly show i won't get in the
details about what this man did to
multiple children but let me just say
some of the worst atrocities a human
being could commit against a child
that guy threatens to kill and carve out
the heart of rittenhouse and rittenhouse
runs for his life screaming friendly
friendly friendly and then rosenbaum
grabs his gun after his friend
zaminsky fires around in the air
this kid's life hangs in the balance and
ojeda sitting there says i am going to
make up fake news
that will rile up people who already
rided before and killed people
tell me that's not evil
it's the very least i disagree with you
absolutely this is all designed by by
plan i think there's going to be a lot
of civil unrest i think a lot of this is
directed towards a divide and conquer
agenda i think this is meant to happen
on purpose and i think there's a reason
why the media is acting like a fire
department that's not putting out water
but adding fuel to all the fires that
already are out there and sparking this
larger division there's a reason anna
kasparian of the young turks believed
that kyle was running after people and
shooting them because of
fake news that gets promoted on social
media but you dare question the
narrative on social media you get taken
down there's people that were docs
there's people that got fired for for
supporting kyle rittenhouse from the
very beginning of this even before the
trial even began but now luckily thank
goodness
we're able to see a trial we're able to
see a live stream we're able to see a
side of the story that we would never
see if it wasn't for the mainstream
media that keeps telling a different
side of the story usa today vanity fair
all these mainstream media institutions
msnbc takes the cake are just literally
going berserk and insane thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you